kampf gegen hass und hetze mit einem
neun-punkte-plan versucht die
bundesregierung rechte gewalt in den
griff zu bekommen
kein weltklimagipfel in chile wegen der
anhaltenden unruhen hat die regierung
die internationale großveranstaltungen
abgesagt
feuer außer kontrolle in kalifornien
sind zehntausende auf der flucht starke
winde drohen die lage weiter zu
verschaffen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara halbe guten abend und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
mittwoch an meiner seite ist für den
sport norbert lehmann schön und auch
familie die morde des nsu der tod von
walter lübke zuletzt der angriff auf die
synagoge in halle innenminister seehofer
spricht von einer linie rechtsextremer
hassverbrechen in deutschland mit einem
neun punkte plan will die
bundesregierung jetzt betroffene besser
schützen
zum beispiel mit der verschärfung des
waffenrechts wer künftig einen
waffenschein beantragt soll vom
verfassungsschutz überprüft werden
kommunalpolitiker sollen sich besser vor
anfeindungen schützen können
und wer im internet hetzt den drohen
härtere strafen nicole diekmann
baden württembergs antisemitismus
beauftragter steigt aus nach jahrelangen
auch wissenschaftlichen warnungen vor
digitaler radikalisierung schließe ich
meine privaten account auf facebook
twitter und instagram schreibt er auf
twitter
nur ein beispiel das kabinett will nicht
vor hass und hetze kapitulieren
es geht darum schwerstkriminalität
verbrecher zu identifizieren
insbesondere in bereichen wo wir heute
noch in hohem maß auf freiwilligkeit der
zusammenarbeit mit
dienstleistungsanbietern angewiesen sind
die konsequenz ausfällen wie der mord am
kasseler regierungspräsidenten lübker
oder dem anschlag auf die synagoge in
halle seien unter anderem sein
plattformen wie facebook und twitter zu
verpflichten strafbares zu melden und
zwar einer noch zu schaffenden
zentralstelle beim bundeskriminalamt
sowie die verschärfung des beleidigungs
§ 185 weil es eine andere qualität hat
ob sie jetzt in der kneipe beleidigt
werden wo sie selbst und vielleicht noch
einige teilnehmer drumherum das
mitbekommen oder ob es eben im netz
geschieht wer die wachsende zahl an
anzeigen dann bearbeiten soll steht
nicht im papier staatsanwälte etwa die
sich mit dem thema beschäftigen absolute
ausnahme wenn wir auf 100000 oder
vielleicht sogar millionen von verfahren
schauen müssen wir da auch personal
technisch verstärkt werden auch die
grünen skeptisch die milliardenschweren
plattformen seien nicht kooperativ
daran würden auch diese pläne nichts
ändern bei uns gibt's kaffee kränzchen
im bundeskanzleramt mit facebook und
deswegen kann ich nur sagen wir müssen
endlich eine vernünftige regulierung
beziehung zu diesen digital konzernen
bekommen sonst werden wir dieses problem
nicht los bis ende des jahres soll das
paket beschlossen sein
facebook und twitter kommentierten es
auf zdf anfrage heute nicht und noch
jemanden möchte die bundesregierung mit
diesem paket künftig besser schützen
ärzte und pfleger in notaufnahmen
wer sie angreift muss mit härteren
strafen rechnen
gewalt in ambulanzen sei inzwischen
vielerorts normalität geworden berichten
kliniken in knapp drei viertel aller
krankenhäuser wurden helfer schon einmal
körperlich angegangen und beschimpft
cornelia strauß berichtet
diese türen waren früher offen alle
sollten unmittelbar zugang in die
notaufnahme der charité am campus
virchow klinikum haben heute helfen
sicherheitstüren zu kontrollieren wer
ein- und ausgeht das ist notwendig seit
ärzte und pfleger zunehmend von
patienten und ihren angehörigen
angegriffen werden
das ganz schnell dass man beschimpft
wird angeschrieben wird was ist das dann
hier für ein mist laden oder auch mal am
kittel kurz festhalten einige patienten
stehen unter drogeneinfluss ein anderes
problem sind sehr lange wartezeiten
bundesweit werden notaufnahmen zunehmend
wegen alltäglicher wehwehchen aufgesucht
notfallversorgung wird mit
dienstleistungen verwechselt außerdem
beobachten mediziner eine gewisse form
es ist ein wandel in der gesellschaft
liegen patienten kommen nicht mit
pralinen und blumen und bedanken sich
dass es irgendwie nett war und dass sie
versorgt worden sind sondern sie haben
ja das messer in der tasche und drohen
uns erde warum es denn jetzt hier so
lange dort gesundheitsminister sparen
zufolge beklagen drei von vier
krankenhäusern übergriffe in ihren
notaufnahmen das können wir als einzelne
bürger nicht akzeptieren dass können wir
eben aber auch als staat nicht
akzeptieren oder jemand der gerade im
einsatz ist um anderen zu helfen
anzugreifen muss aus meiner sicht noch
härter und klara bestraft werden mit bis
zu fünf jahren haft an der charité
nehmen mittlerweile aller ärzte und
pfleger an einem deeskalationstraining
und seminar teil um die kommunikation zu
verbessern die idee wer weiß dass
erwarten muss hat vielleicht mehr
verständnis für andere patienten und für
die die sie versorgen die folgen der
schwächelnden wirtschaft zeigt sich
heute an zwei zahlen zuerst zum
arbeitsmarkt da ist der rückgang der
arbeitslosen geringer als sonst im
herbst nach angaben der bundesagentur
für arbeit waren im oktober 2 millionen
204.000 menschen ohne job das sind
30.000 weniger als im september und fast
so viel wie im vergangenen jahr die
arbeitslosenquote 4,8 prozent und dann
noch die steuerschätzung danach steigen
die einnahmen zwar allerdings langsamer
bund länder und kommunen müssen bis 2023
mit 7,1 milliarden euro weniger rechnen
als noch im mai vermutet andreas künast
fasst zusammen es wird bevor es
schlechter wird noch einmal besser der
bund kann sogar mit vier milliarden euro
mehr rechnen als im frühjahr
vorausgesagt mehr steuern und niedrige
zinsen heißt die schuldenuhr des bundes
der steuerzahler läuft weiter rückwärts
pro sekunde sinken deutschlands schulden
um 66 euro selbstlob des finanzministers
geht unserem land wirtschaftlich weiter
gut die steuereinnahmen entsprechen sich
entwickeln sich entsprechend stabil
trotz der eintrübung der weltwirtschaft
trotz internationaler handelskonflikte
und auch trotz des drohnen bresset
mittelfristig aber rechnet der
arbeitskreis steuerschätzung mit weniger
einnahmen immer mühsam ernährt sich das
eichhörnchen auch weil die
bundesregierung selbst ihre
wachstumsprognose von 1,5 auf 1,0
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts
korrigiert hat die fdp wiederspricht
weil die steuereinnahmen auch
langfristig stiegen müssten die bürger
entlastet werden
beispielsweise der solidaritätszuschlag
sollte für alle und schnellstmöglich und
vollständig entfallen dass der
finanzminister das steuerplus
investieren soll verlangen die
wirtschaftsverbände aber auch linke und
grüne
herr scholz muss endlich das verbohrte
dogma der schwarzen null aufgeben
das hat der finanzminister nicht vor
zwar wird die lage schlechter aber nicht
schlecht genug überraschende nachricht
aus chile das land will wegen der
anhaltenden unruhen nicht die
weltklimakonferenz ausrichten
politiker aus aller welt wollten sich
dort im dezember treffen
seit tagen demonstrieren in chile
hunderttausende zum teil gewaltsam gegen
die soziale und wirtschaftliche
ungleichheit mindestens 20 menschen
kamen ums leben christophe hocke rat
berichtet völlig unbeeindruckt von der
immer entschlosseneren staatsmacht
machen sie einfach weiter
die proteste in chile reißen nicht ab
was begann als unmut über eine
preiserhöhung der u-bahn ist längst eine
gewaltige und gewalttätige
generalabrechnung mit der politik des
präsidenten und der hat heute eine
entscheidung zu verkünden die man wohl
auch als kapitulation vor den massen
interpretieren dürfte sowohl den asien
pazifik gipfel als auch die
weltklimakonferenz die in santiago
hätten stattfinden sollen sagt er
diese entscheidung bereitet uns große
schmerzen sagt er aber ein präsident
muss immer die bedürfnisse seiner
landsleute an erste stelle setzen und
die wollen keine prestigeträchtigen
gipfel sondern soziale veränderungen das
was wir fordern ist doch sehr überlegt
das land braucht eine echte wende und
das schnell
sonst werden sich immer mehr menschen
auf leben mit höheren renten und
mindestlöhnen sowie einer
kabinettsumbildung versucht der
präsident gegen zu steuern
doch bislang scheint kein mittel gegen
die wut der menschen zu wirken
die lage in chile eskaliert weiter seit
mehr als acht jahren wütet in syrien der
bürgerkrieg nun haben sich erstmals
vertreter von regierung opposition und
zivilgesellschaft gemeinsam an den
verhandlungstisch gesetzt
der un-sondergesandte für syrien
peterson sprach von einem historischen
moment
mit unterstützung der vereinten nationen
soll eine neue verfassung ausgearbeitet
und damit ein friedensprozess in gang
gesetzt werden
zur wirtschaft in der kriselnden
autobranche könnte es bald einen neuen
riesen geben die fiat gruppe und der
französische konzern verhandeln über
eine fusion
durch den zusammenschluss würde aus fiat
mit seinem us-partner chrysler und der
opel mutter für so der viertgrößte
autohersteller der welt mit zuletzt
insgesamt 8,7 millionen verkauften autos
pro jahr
die börsen sind entzückt gewerkschaften
fürchten um arbeitsplätze an seinem
stern berichtet gemeinsam gegen die
krise
peugeot und fiat chrysler beide brauchen
partner denn der kampf am automarkt wird
immer härter die mega fusion könnte
helfen etwa beim thema elektromobilität
hier nämlich hinten die beiden
autokonzerne hinterher
zum anderen spielt größe eine gewichtige
rolle um gegen wettbewerber wie den
volkswagen konzern erfolgreich sein zu
können
da geht es um hohe stückzahlen um die
enormen entwicklungskosten etwa in neue
technologien über möglichst viele
fahrzeuge zu
fiat chrysler etwa mit der marke jeep
will durch die verbindung neue kunden in
europa und asien an land ziehen
die peugeot gruppe mit zitronen und opel
will mehr autos bei den amerikanern
verkaufen neue auto allianzen mit
marktmacht zusammen kämen der peugeot
konzern und die fiat chrysler gruppe auf
einen umsatz von fast 200 milliarden
euro und auf mehr als 400.000
mitarbeiter diese fusion würde bedeuten
dass man sicherlich harte einschnitte
auch machen muss bei den
produktionsstätten und damit auch bei
den beschäftigten insbesondere in den
werken etwa in italien aber auch
mitarbeiter in deutschland könnte es
wieder treffen
2017 hatte die peugeot gruppe opel
geschluckt seitdem werden hier immer
mehr stellen abgebaut
die umstrittene gaspipeline nord stream
2 kommt denn auch dänemark hat jetzt
grünes licht gegeben die dortige energie
behörde erteilte die letzte benötigte
baugenehmigung für die 1200 kilometer
lange gasleitung durch die ostsee sie
soll ab kommendem jahr russisches gas
nach deutschland bringen
vor allem die usa kritisieren europa
mache sich damit zu abhängig von
russland vor zweieinhalb jahren starben
im londoner krempelt aua mehr als 70
menschen die bilder des brennenden
hochhauses gingen um die welt
ein untersuchungsbericht macht der
feuerwehr jetzt schwere vorwürfe sie
habe die evakuierung des gebäudes zu
spät angeordnet die einsatzkräfte aber
weisen das zurück lassen die airline
antworten und gerechtigkeit das ist es
was die angehörigen der 72 todesopfer
des brandes im londoner grant feldtor
wollen die ergebnisse des
untersuchungsausschusses sollen dabei
helfen
vor allem quält die frage hätten mehr
menschen gerettet werden können einige
überlebten nur weil sie sich der
aufforderung der feuerwehr in ihren
wohnungen zu bleiben widersetzten
ich habe diese anweisung komplett
ignoriert und wir sind heil
herausgekommen
glaube viele hätten gerettet werden
können wenn sie rechtzeitig das gebäude
verlassen hätten andere hörten auf die
feuerwehr wie der onkel karl muss sie
liest er im obersten stockwerk wohnte er
war ruhig und gefasst denn sie hatten
ihm ja gesagt er solle bleiben
sie wissen wo er sei und sie würden
kommen um ihn zu holen doch schließlich
kam der rauch dann in seine wohnung und
der stab der bericht lobt ausdrücklich
den mut der feuerwehrleute der feuerwehr
insgesamt aber werden schwerwiegende
versäumnisse vorgeworfen die
einsatzkräfte sehen sich zu unrecht an
den pranger gestellt schließlich habe
die fassadenverkleidung aus leicht
brennbarem material bestanden
es fühlt sich so an als wenn wir nun für
20 jahre fehler bei bauplanungen und
politik verantwortlich gemacht werden
doch im detail wird all dies erst in
phase 2 der untersuchung nächstes jahr
unter die lupe genommen
auf antworten und gerechtigkeit müssen
die angehörigen der grenze opfer also
noch länger warten seit mehr als einer
woche brennt es in kalifornien und die
lage verschärft sich weiter stürme in
hurrikan-stärke werden erwartet sie
könnten die wald und buschbrände weiter
anheizen
besonders zwei feuer machen den
einsatzkräften derzeit große probleme
bei los angeles ist ein villenvorort
akut bedroht und auch nördlich von san
francisco wütet ein großbrand drittel
jäger berichtet das größte feuer wütet
nördlich von san francisco in dem
weinanbaugebiet sonoma county brennt es
auf einer fläche so groß wie münchen gut
4000 feuerwehrleute kämpfen hier rund um
die uhr teilweise unter
lebensgefährlichen bedingungen
wir machen das hier schon seit ein paar
tagen und nächten wir sind müde
wir müssen da einfach durch auch im
süden kaliforniens ist die lage
dramatisch hier haben die behörden nun
in weiten teilen die höchste
gefahrenstufe ausgerufen
das gab es noch nie nördlich von los
angeles ist ein weiteres großfeuer
ausgebrochen
hier werden starke windböen von bis zu
130 stundenkilometern erwartet die die
brände weiter anfachen werden
wir haben es mit einer großen
herausforderung zu tun in 43
kalifornischen bezirken herrscht die
höchste alarmstufe
wir erwarten historisch starke winde
insgesamt sind etwa 200.000 menschen
aufgerufen ihr zuhause zu verlassen
tausende häuser sind bereits zerstört
die behörden haben in weiten teilen des
küstenstaat es evakuierungszonen
angerichtet ich bin bedrückt eine
freundin hat bereits wie zuhause
verloren das ist wirklich schlimm
der amerikanische wetterdienst sagt
voraus dass es auch in den nächsten
sieben tagen nicht regnen wird auf
trockenem boden braucht es da nur einen
funken um neue brände auszulösen
wir sind beim spagat dfb-pokal janta
gab's gestern abend fast eine faustdicke
überraschung zweitligist bochum führte
bis zur 83
minute mit 1 0 gegen den
titelverteidiger aber dann kamen die
bayern und dauer joker müller schoss die
münchner
deshalb für eine ins achtelfinale die
bayern spielen wieder nicht wie eine
spitzenmannschaft ein fehlpassfestival
70 minuten lang und ein eigentor durch
alfonso davis und glücklich aber bochum
der drittletzte der zweiten liga führt
nicht unverdient die bayern brauchen
lewandowski der pole wird eingewechselt
die räume werden größer in ambri steht
frei
sieben minuten vor dem ende erst der
ausgleich heute speziell ich muss man
sagen eine schlechte leistung von uns
lief sehr viel schief
eine minute vor schluss thomas müller
stochert den ball ins tor
egal wie die bayern nach dem motto
hauptsache gewonnen
die pokalsensation findet in saarbrücken
statt der dort die gfc ein viertligist
hat den ehemaligen kölner dirk lottner
als trainer
ausgerechnet dessen ex klub den fc
werfen sie aus dem wettbewerb durch
tobias jänicke 32 in das schluss minute
das fühlt sich einfach geil an mit einem
regionalligisten östlichen auszuschalten
köln der ehemalige österreichische ski
langläufer max hauke ist vom landgericht
augsburg wegen schweren sportbetrugs zu
einer fünfmonatigen bewährungsstrafe
verurteilt worden
hauk hatte zugegeben sowohl
wachstumshormone genommen als auch
blutdoping betrieben zu haben
dafür habe er dem deutschen
sportmediziner mag esposito 10.000 euro
bezahlt der doping skandal wurde vor
acht monaten in der so genannten
operation aderlass aufgedeckt
nach jan lennard struff hat auch
alexander zverev beim atp masters
turnier in paris das achtelfinale
erreicht der 22 jährige hamburger
besiegte gestern abend den spanier
fernando verdasco souverän mit 6 1 und 6
nach nur 56 minuten verwandelte es wäre
seinen ersten matchball und sammelte
dadurch weitere wichtige punkte für die
qualifikation für das atp finale der
besten acht in london
es trifft einen morgen achtelfinale auf
dem kanadier denis schapowalow jetzt
kommen die lottozahlen die gewinnzahlen
lauten 11 22 23 28 44 48 und die
superzahl 9 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7
das wetter am reformationstag morgen
soll fast überall sonnig werden letzte
wolken ziehen jedoch noch über den
südwesten mehr dazu gleich von gunther
tiersch marietta slomka freut sich im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn auf
sie und hier begrüßt sie morgen petra
gerster haben sie noch einen
unbeschwerten abend danke für ihr
interesse und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
und am liebe zuschauer morgen wird
endlich auch wieder an den alten trocken
werden aber heute nacht müssen sie dort
noch mit regen rechnen
ein wolken paket wird noch mal
durchziehen mit regen direkt an den
alpen zieht es nach osten
wir bleiben an der kalten seite der
hochdruckgebiete und die wolken werden
morgen mehr zu den alpen zurück beträgt
es wird also auch in bayern wieder ganz
freundlich werden heute nacht haben wir
den regen noch vom schwarzwald bis ins
allgäu dann später auch berchtesgaden
morgen früh wird dieser regen dann wohl
meist durchgezogen sein
ansonsten haben ein paar nebelfelder
aber meist würde sie ja sternen klar und
richtig frostig also im norden minus 1
bis minus fünf grad genauso hier im
osten werden dass im südwesten noch mal
plus vier bis plus sieben grad mild
bleibt da liegen ja auch die regenwolken
und morgen heißt es auch dort am
mildesten vom niederrhein etwa bis ins
allgäu 10 12 grad sind das sonst ist es
kühler mit fünf bis acht grad etwa aber
es wird ja ein sonniger tag werden
wunderbar wenn sich der nebel aufgelöst
hat es wird auch nur ein schwacher bis
mäßiger ostwind dazu einzig allein im
südwesten vom schwarzwald bis ins allgäu
na da wird ein bisschen bewölkter seien
am bodensee könnte es tatsächlich den
ganzen tag über trüb bleiben ja die
aussichten sehen dann wieder regnerisch
aus freitag geht es im westen los
wochenende wird nass es wird sehr windig
aber ein bisschen milder
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und macht es gut